Guten Abend. Ich heiße Hüssein Czellig. Ich möchte mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen,
aber zunächst brauche ich ein paar allgemeine Informationen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Nadja Maga.
Nadja Maga. Könnten Sie die Vor- und Nachname langsam ustavieren?
Ja, der Vorname N, die Nordpol, A, D, J, A, Nadja.
Nadja, ja.
Und der Familienname Maga, M, A, G, E, R.
Maga.
Mhm.
Frau Maga, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 57 noch.
57, okay.
Wo war Sie genau geworden?
Am 5.07.67.
67, okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1.63.
Wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, leider. Ja, ich weiß genau. Wie 71 Kilo.
71 Kilo.
Also, ich mache meinem Namen keine Ehre. Ich bin nicht Maga.
Mhm.
Okay.
Frau Maga, welche Beschwerde haben Sie?
Ja, also mein Bauch macht mir große Probleme, wissen Sie?
Ich habe eigentlich schon geraume Zeitbau.
Eigentlich ging das schon vor drei Wochen los.
Insbesondere nach dem Essen.
Und, also, da habe ich solchen Druck auf dem Oberbauch.
Also, ja, und das ist jetzt irgendwie die letzten Tage immer schlimmer geworden.
Mir wurde jetzt die letzten Tage so schlecht.
Und gestern Abend ist mir das aufgefallen.
Da hatte ich mit einmal,
als ich auf der Toilette war und ein Stuhlgang hatte,
habe ich gesehen, dass das ganz blutig war.
Und, oh, da habe ich dann doch ein bisschen Schreck bekommen.
Ja.
Und ja, und heute Morgen war es dann wirklich so,
dass da nicht nur Blut war,
sondern das sah alles ganz schwarz aus.
Ja, und ja, das hat mir dann schon ein bisschen Angst gemacht.
Ja, und dann habe ich damit,
ich muss heute jetzt unbedingt mal hierher kommen.
Okay.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Aber wie?
Ja, mir ist sehr, sehr schlecht.
Ich musste mich zwar noch nicht übergeben,
aber ich habe auch ständig so ein bisschen Sohn brennen
und habe immer so das Gefühl, dass es so kurz davor.
Ja, und das Essen schmeckt mir zurzeit überhaupt nicht.
Schön.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, heftige Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Wo haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Mittige, rechts- oder links-?
Nein, die sind schon in der Mitte,
aber also nicht unten im Bauch,
sondern mehr so im Oberbauch.
Mittige Oberbauch.
Und das hat ganz langsam angefangen.
Also erst war das eben so ein bisschen Druck nach den Mahlzeilen
und jetzt ist es wirklich von Tag zu Tag,
kann man sagen, schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben,
zum Beispiel Dove, Drückent oder Grafartik?
Ja, also Drückent, das habe ich ja schon gesagt,
dass das so ein ganz heftiger Druck ist.
Und manchmal auch so ein bisschen so Wellenförmig,
aber eigentlich ist der Schmerz jetzt ständig da.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Oh, das habe ich nicht gemessen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht fieberig.
Ich fühle mich total schlapp, ja.
Aber ja, mir schmeckt auch das Essen nicht
und ich habe jetzt schon tagelang nicht gut gegessen.
Und insofern, ja, aber fieberig im eigentlichen Sinne,
würde ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Stuhl haben Sie Blut gesehen.
Ja, also gestern habe ich das gesehen,
dass da so Blutspuren waren
und dann heute Morgen habe ich eben gesehen,
dass das ganz schwarz aussah der Stuhl war.
Heute Morgen ist es schwarz, ja.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre, haben Sie beim Wasser lassen Probleme?
Ne, Gott hat nicht, nein, eigentlich nicht.
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerte?
Ne, so was kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Also, dann, was weiß ich denn?
Also, nee, nach dem Essen, ich konnte immer alles gut vertragen
und war eigentlich nie so,
dass ich Probleme hatte mit dem Bauch.
Wurden Sie schon einmal ein Magenspiegelung?
Magenspiegelung, da kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Ich glaube nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
die Farbe Ihrer Haut veränderte?
Ob sich die Farbe meiner Haut verändert hat,
das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Also, ja, jetzt im Sommer ist man ein bisschen mehr braun
als im Winter, weil man mehr in der Sonne ist.
Aber ansonsten würde ich nicht sagen,
dass meine Haut komisch aussieht.
Sind die Schmerzen im Lauf der Zeit gewandert?
Gewandert?
Ne, das ist immer an der gleichen Stelle eigentlich.
Nicht gewandert, okay.
Wie stark ist die Schmerzen,
die Schmerzen sind auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
wobei ein sehr leicht,
sehr stark ist?
Das sind schon,
wenn das gerade so direkt nach dem Essen ist,
dann sind das Wahnsinnschmerzen.
Am Anfang würde ich sagen,
wenn man morgens aufwacht und noch nichts Böses an,
da merkt man ein bisschen den Druck,
da ist es vielleicht so bei 5 bis 6,
aber direkt nach dem Essen würde ich sagen,
da sind die wirklich so heftig,
dass 8 von 10 würde ich sagen.
8 von 10.
Und eben diese Übelkeit,
dass ich für mich wirklich richtig elendig auch im Blick.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, ja.
Aber Sie haben sich nicht übergeben.
Nein, zum Glück nicht mehr,
aber das mache ich gar nicht gerne.
Haben Sie Herz gelaufen, Herz, da sind Herz, apetit?
Ja, total ja, lausig,
das dachte ich ja schon,
dass es mir überhaupt nicht schmeckt.
Ich habe auch tatsächlich,
in den letzten 2 Wochen,
habe ich gemerkt, ich habe 2 kg abgenommen.
2 kg?
Haben Sie Schütterfrost nach Schweiß?
Nein, ich habe nur eben diese krassen Bauchschmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
Sie haben im Achselhöhe oder
in anderen Bereichen ein Knoten?
Knoten?
Ja, oder Schwellungen?
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Haben Sie Schlafstoren?
Nein, zurzeit schlafe ich natürlich nicht so wahnsinnig gut,
weil ich eben diese Bauchschmerzen habe
und weil ich das Gefühl habe,
ja, ich muss vielleicht auf die Toilette oder so,
aber grundsätzlich eigentlich
kann ich sonst ganz gut schlafen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Vorherkrankungen?
Ja, das, was alle in meinem Alter haben.
Ich habe ein bisschen hohem Blutdruck
und ich habe auch ein bisschen hohe Blutfettwerte.
Was mich schon seit Jahren begleitet,
das ist so eine chronische Schuppenflechte.
Das habe ich aber schon als junges Mädchen angekommen.
Und da gibt es so etwas,
was ich am Haaransatz habe,
ich da so stellen
und auch hier oben, außen an den Oberarmen
und da muss ich halt hin und wieder mal
Cortison-Salbe anwenden, wenn es zu schlimm wird.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder?
Nein, ich nehme nur, wenn es unangenehm ist,
wenn es gerade mal so blüht.
Das ist nicht ständig so schlimm.
Okay.
Was haben Sie vorhin gesagt?
Ne, also, ja, was ich,
was ich im letzten Jahr, Ende des letzten Jahren,
da hatte ich mal eine Trombose in dem linken Bein.
Da habe ich für kurze Zeit dann so Medikamente bekommen,
um das Blutflüssig zu machen
und habe auch dann Kompressonstrumfe getragen.
Aber das ist jetzt zu Ende.
Und dann, ja, vor Jahren
hatte ich mal Probleme,
da hatte ich nie ein Stein,
aber da hatte ich zwar Schmerzen,
aber das waren andere Schmerzen, als jetzt.
Die waren mehr so hinten im Rücken
und dann im Unterbauch.
Das waren auch hechtige Schmerzen.
Da habe ich seinerzeit
eine so eine Haarliter-Schiene bekommen
und die Steine sind dann abgegangen,
aber jetzt die Schmerzen sind völlig anders.
Vor einem Jahr, oder?
Nein, das ist schon viele Jahre her.
Also, das ist bestimmt schon sechs Jahre her.
Ja, sechs Jahre.
Okay.
Welche Seite hatten Sie in Ihren Steinen?
Rechts oder links?
Ja, auf der linken Seite.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt,
hohe Bluthochdruck haben Sie?
Ja, das hat man schon mal so festgestellt.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie da gehen?
Ja, ich nehme ein Blutdruckmittel,
aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das heißt.
Und dann habe ich,
habe von meinem Haus,
wegen der Fettwerte,
hat er mir Statine verschrieben
und die nehme ich halt abends immer ein.
Name der Statine?
Oh, das kann ich Ihnen auch nicht sagen.
Also, die Packung liegen zu Hause auf meinem Essdisch.
Dosierung?
Ja, also eben ein, ein Jahr, ein letzer Abend.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich halt nicht nichts ein.
Also, das weiß ich, wenn ich mal starke Kopfschmerzen habe
oder so, dann nehme ich auch mal
Niveauprophäen oder Aspirin, je nachdem, was ich gerade so da habe.
Okay.
Gehen Sie Bluthochdruck, was nehmen Sie?
Ich habe nicht gut verstanden.
Ja, ich habe da ein Medikament,
kann das sein?
Rami-Pril ist das glaube ich.
Ja, das kann sein.
Aber fragen Sie mich nicht, wie viel Gramm das sind.
Also, da nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
Okay.
Und ich messe hin und wieder und jetzt ist der Blutdruck,
also so an die Hand gut eingestellt.
Okay.
Können Sie mir nach dem Gespräch,
die Kontakte hat in Ihres Hausassists gegeben?
Ja, natürlich, den kann ich Ihnen sagen.
Ich kann Ihnen sprechen.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert,
außer Nähresteine?
Nee, sonst noch nie.
Nein.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie allergiert gegen etwas?
Das Einzige, wo ich weiß,
dass ich das nicht gut vertragen kann,
ist der Kleber von braunem Pflaster.
Ja, braunem Pflaster.
Ja, also da kriege ich sofort so rote Hautstibchen
und das Juckt und deswegen nehme ich immer weißes Pflaster,
wenn ich etwas habe.
Okay.
Aber Sie noch andere allergieren?
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Bisher war ich immer ziemlich gesund, fand ich.
Okay.
Herr Maik,
Magier,
Rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Ja, also ich rauche,
seit ich 30 bin, ja.
Aber ich rauche eigentlich nicht viel.
Ich rauche also kein Päckchen am Tag.
Also wenn das so 15 Zigaretten sind am Tag,
dann ja, dann ist es auch schon viel.
Seit 14,
ab dem 14. Lebensjahr rauchen Sie?
Ja, seit dem 30. Lebensjahr.
Ja, da habe ich angefangen, ja, das war,
als ich dann meine Stelle angefangen habe
und alle Kollegen haben mitgeraucht
und ja, da habe ich halt auch mitgeraucht.
Okay.
Wie kenne ich das eigentlich? Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja, also ja, ich trinke ein bis zwei Bier am Abend
unter der Woche
und manchmal, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt,
man natürlich auch mal ein Glas Sekt oder ein Glas Wein
oder je nachdem, was es zu essen gibt, aber
so Schnepse oder sowas trinke ich überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Nee, die Drogen konsumiere ich nur wirklich nicht.
Nein.
Und was machen Sie, Belfni?
Ich arbeite als Buchhändlerin.
Buchhändler?
Haben Sie Stress auf der Arbeit oder?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Das ist ein schönes Arbeit.
Man ist von schönen Dingen umgeben
und ja, also in der Weihnachtszeit ist natürlich Stress
oder ja, vor Feiertagen und so, aber eigentlich
vor der Buchmesse, aber eigentlich muss ich sagen,
ist das ein schönes Arbeiten.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, das sind aber keine leiblichen Kinder.
Das sind meine Stiefkinder.
Mein Mann hat die mit in die Ehe gebracht, die beiden.
Ja, wir haben das spät geheiratet.
Okay.
Sind in Ihrer Familie irgendein Brötchen vor der Krankung
gern bekannt, weil Vater oder Mutter?
Also, mein Vater, der ist tragisch eigentlich
ein Folgen eines Verkehrsunfalls gestorben
und der war aber so viel, ich weiß, nicht irgendwie krank
oder so.
Und bei meiner Mutter, da ist es so, jetzt,
die ist natürlich auch schon in einem sehr hohen Alter
und da haben die den Verdacht, dass sie, das wird gerade untersucht,
die ist gerade in Behandlung wegen einer so einer offenen
Stelle am Bein und die vermuten, dass sie eine Durchblutungsstörung
in den Beinen hat.
Wie alt ist Ihre Mutter?
Ja, die ist ja schon weit über 80, die ist 87.
87, okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder.
Ein Bruder.
Wie alt ist er?
Er ist zwei Jahre älter als ich, aber wir haben nicht viel Kontakt,
ich kann Ihnen nicht viel über den erzählen.
Ja, wissen Sie, wie es denn Sie gesund ist?
Ob er gesund ist?
Ja.
So viel ich weiß, fühlt demnächst?
Okay.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt,
haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich will jetzt natürlich schon wissen, was kann das sein,
was steckt dahinter, hinter diesen Bauchschmerzen
und hinter dieser Übelkeit und natürlich auch,
was kann man dagegen tun?
Ja, allein auf Basis unseres Gespräch
kann ich noch keine Diagnose stellen.
Wir brauchen noch einige Untersuchungen,
ich kann Ihnen mehr sagen.
Was machen wir denn für Untersuchungen?
Ja, ich muss erstmal körperliche Untersuchen,
danach werde ich Blut abnehmen
und dann ein Bauchutröscher veranlassen.
Veranlassen, okay, ja gut.
Das ist ja nicht schmerzhaft.
Ein Bauchultraschall, das ist nicht schmerzhaft, oder?
Nein, nein, nicht schmerzhaft.
Keine Schmerzen, keine...
Keine Strahlung gelassen?
Keine Strahlung, ja.
Es hat keine Strahlung, ja.
Okay, gut.
Aber ich muss jetzt nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben, oder?
Jetzt kann ich Ihnen nicht genau sagen,
aber Sie, wir müssen da etwas Ergebnis erwarten.
Das Ergebnis müssen wir abwarten.
Ja, okay, dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Okay, möchte ich jemand etwas fragen?
Wurden Sie schon mal lokaliert?
Das hat er gefragt, ich habe nur von der Hanleiterschiene erzählt,
dass man ja als Grenzwertigkeit, Operation oder Eingriff ansehen kann.
Aber sonst keine Operation bekannt.
Was mir gerade auffällt, das Einzige, was er nicht gefragt hat,
ist glaube ich im Status, ne?
Im Status haben Sie nicht gefragt?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefragt, ja.
Aber ich denke mal auch, Gefäß bemerkt,
dann nochmal, ah, gynäkologische Anamnese, ja.
Na gut, ich bin so alt, ja, mit 57.
Ja, braucht nur nicht mehr gynäkologische Anamnese.
Ja.
Entschuldigung, bemerken Sie, haben Sie etwas anders gegessen,
sei Sie beschwerden, angefangen?
Das ist eine gute Frage, ja.
Nein, ich habe ganz normal gegessen.
Also nicht irgendwelche aufregenden, besonderen Schafen
oder Fettigen oder so Sachen gegessen,
sondern nach einem ganz normalen Essen gegen das los.
Was ich sonst auch so esse.
Haben Sie Gefäß-Erweiterung bemerkt auf der Haut,
Bauchhaut oder wie Spine, oder?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Da müssen Sie mich nachher mal aufklären,
was es damit aus sich hat.
Ja, wann sieht man das?
Was meinen Sie, Herr Kollerge?
Er meint glaube ich eine starke Läubinzahl.
Leber Probleme, Syrosa oder für, ich möchte fragen.
Speiderneville.
Ja, Speiderneville.
Ja, wie eine, wie Spinder habe ich.
Spinder habe ich verstanden.
Also kannst du so erweiterte Ehlärchen auf der Haut.
Ja, meinen Sie sowas?
Ja, ja, richtig.
Ah ja, okay.
Aber ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Was es alles gibt.
Ja, ich lerne immer noch etwas dazu.
Haben, bemerken Sie beim Belastung ein Problem,
Probleme zum Beispiel Treppe steigen, Herzrasen, ein bisschen brauchen sie Pause machen, bevor
sie sich beschwerfen?
Also bisher habe ich das nicht gemerkt, dass ich irgendwie belastet bin, dass ich Pause
machen muss auf der Treppe oder so, aber jetzt geht es mir halt vom Bauch her so schlecht,
dass ich mich auch überhaupt nicht belaste, seit einigen Tagen.
Haben Sie Schwellung in der Beine oder Bauch bemerkt?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Dr.
Schillig, Sie sagen, gescheit, wenn Sie soweit sind.
Schönen Abend Frau Obererstin, ich habe heute eine neue Partie und aufgenommen,
dass Sie seither haben.
Ich würde Ihnen Sie vorstellen.
Gut, natürlich.
Klar, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Die Patiente ist Nadja Mager, 57-jährige Patientin.
Sie ist 1,63 m groß und sie wiegt 71 kg schwer.
Sie ist 71 kg schwer oder wiegt 71 kg schwer?
Ja, wiegt 71 kg schwer, genau.
Die Patiente stelle sich seit 3 Wochen bestehender, intermittierender Oberbauchschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen sind drückend und grafartig.
Die Schmerzen haben langsam begonnen.
Und prokrediert.
Die Schmerzen wurden nach dem Essen 8 m mit 8 von 10 und morgens mit 6 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Die Patiente hat gestern einmal Hematokäsie und heute Morgen auch einmal Melana im Schuttel gesehen.
Die Patiente hat Übelkeit, aber die MS ist für die Verneidung.
Die Patiente hat auch Soprennen, auch Pyrosis.
Sie haben keine ähnliche Beschwerden, bis sie keine Magischpiegel durchgeführt wurden.
Sie haben auch in Appetence seit 2 Wochen abgenommen.
Sie gab an, dass sie in den letzten 2 Wochen 2 kg abgenommen hat.
Sie gab einen Gewichtsverlust von 2 kg innerhalb von 2 Wochen an.
Die restliche Vegetationen haben sie aber unaufwählig.
Sie können vor der Krankheit sein, bei der Patiente bekannt.
Sie haben Atelierhypertonin, Hyperlipidemia und Syrias.
Die Patiente nehme regelmäßig Samipri, 2 Mal, einmal, morgens, einmal und abends.
Die Patiente nehme auch Statin, einmal, abends.
Die Patiente verwendet Cortisol Salve bei Bedarf.
Sie haben auch Soprennen, auch bei Bedarf.
Die Patiente hat letztes Jahr Trombose, die Medikamenten, mit Stuf behandelt.
Mit einem Kompassant Trombone?
Vor 6 Jahren hat die Patiente einen Nierenstein, deswegen wurde bei einem Hanleiter China,
da war sie durchgeführt. Sie haben auch braune Flasche, Allergie.
Die Allergie aus der Flasche ist mit Yukreis.
Die Patiente braucht seit ab dem 13.Jahr 15 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Sie trinken 1 oder 2 Glas Bier, manchmal 1 Glas Zeg oder Wein beim Feier.
Die Trombokonsum wurde vermeint.
Der Vater der Patientin ist bei einem Unfall verstorben.
Da ist nichts über Krankheiten bekannt.
Die Mutter ist 87 Jahre alt und hat eine Urkurskurris wegen einer Durchbrutostöne.
Wie nennt man die Erkrankung?
Die Urkurskurris, Venousen oder Arteriosen.
Wie nennt man die Durchbrutostörung?
Perfekt.
Was vermuten Sie denn jetzt?
Die Annamnistischen Angaben deuten am 1. auf eine Urkursventurkülle hin.
Die Francaire Diagroistich sehe ich ein Urkursdeutende und Maginkarsenum hin.
Was würden Sie mit der Patiente diagnostisch machen?
Ich würde gerne körperliche Untersuchungen machen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Erstmal Metallparameter messen.
Dann muss ich einen Bauch untersuchen.
Abwehrspannung oder Drucksmärzen.
Was machen Sie mit Ihren Augen?
Ich muss auch sich klar kontrollieren.
Woher gucken Sie noch?
Ein Kollege hat gefragt nach Schwellungen.
Ich muss auch Bauchpapieren.
Abtasten.
Was machen Sie sonst für Untersuchungen?
Ich muss ein kleines Blutbild, ein Strungesparameter, Leber und Nierenwerte kontrollieren.
Was erwarten Sie an Laborergebnissen?
Ich erwarte eine Anämie.
Wie geht es weiter mit den Untersuchungen?
Ich muss eine Abdominalunterscheid machen.
Im Rahmen derer könnte man sogar intervenieren.
Was könnte man mit dem Abdomensono ausschließen?
Im Abdomensono muss ich Akutechroesistitis oder Leberkrankungen ausschließen.
Was wäre die Behandlung?
Wir müssen schauen, ob es Helikobacterpillori gibt.
Wenn es Helikobacterpillori gibt, müssen wir Antibiotische Behandlung.
Ich bin gespannt, wie Sie sich über die Patientin auf dem Laufen halten.
Dennoch haben Sie im Arztgespräch geschwächelt.
Sie waren in der Anamnese sehr langsam.
Sie hatten lange Pausen zwischen den einzelnen Fragen.
Nach dem Motto, jetzt muss ich mich sortieren.
Aber das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen dem Überraschungseffekt geschuldet.
Sie waren ja nicht präpariert, dass Sie heute Anamnese machen.
Sie hatten kein Zettel vor sich liegen nach dem Motto, wo muss ich das jetzt machen?
Sie waren ein bisschen überrascht.
Dafür haben Sie sich bravourös geschlagen.
Ich finde auch, Ihre Formulierung von deutschen Sätzen ist ausgezeichnet.
Sie benutzen die Fälle und Formulierungen wirklich sehr gut.
Es ist nicht immer alles super gut verständlich.
Manchmal muss man ein bisschen hinheuchen.
Ich habe auch mal nachgefragt.
Wenn etwas dramatikalisch gar nicht ging, habe ich immer gleich interveniert.
Ich denke immer, dass es besser ist, als nachher mit einer großen Liste zu kommen.
Zumal ich dann auch immer etwas vergesse.
Das hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Sie haben gemerkt beim Arztgespräch.
Sie sind nicht ganz so souverän sprachlich.
Sie mussten etwas rudern und Formulierungen suchen.
Insgesamt war es wirklich so, dass Sie Ihre Prüfung mit großer Gelassenheit entgegensehen können.
Sie gucken sich noch mal ein paar Fälle an.
Ich horche ein paar Anamnesen rein.
Das war sehr überzeugend.
Als Patient habe ich mich bei Ihnen gut aufgehoben gefühlt.
Sehr schön.
Vielen Dank.
Auf nach München.
Das ist ein Fall, der auch ein paar Mal habe ich schon gemacht.
Aber wie gesagt, zuletzt.
Für heute Abend können wir sehr zufrieden nach Hause gehen.